j'aimerais partir d'un mot un peu
étrange de napoléon qui est à
auprès de ses soldats au bivouac un soir
de 1807 avant la bataille d'eylau vous
savez c'est une image d'épinal napoléon
qui fait un peu le démago au milieu de
ses soldats il va manger des patates
avec eux cuites au feu de bois il leur
tire l'oreille vous savez emmanuel
macron fait ça aussi un peu avec ses
ministres il leur tire l'oreille ça veut
dire je suis affectueux me suis quand
même au dessus de vous mais je suis
affectueux
c'est un lieu commun mais sa façon de le
dire est curieuse et je vais vous lire
la la citation exacte
il dit la véritable gloire consiste à se
mettre au dessus de son étang
j'ai une bonne place je suis en preuve
je pourrais vivre dans les délices de ma
capitale eh bien je fais la guerre pour
la gloire de la france je suis au milieu
de vous au bivouac et dans les combats
je puise être tout comme vous atteint
par une balle et c'est là où il ya cette
formule curieuse je me mets au dessus de
mon état et bien la citation mais revenu
tout de suite a en mémoire camp olympien
arménien en m'a donné le thème au delà
et quand nous sommes convenus d'invités
micheline calmy rey ce que dit napoléon
c'est qu'il y à des hommes et des femmes
qui ne se contente pas exercer de
remplir d'accomplir une mission mandat
une fonction mais ils vont toujours un
peu au delà ils font bouger les lignes
c'est vrai pour les empereurs comme pour
les garçons de café les médecins les
enseignants que sais-je beaucoup
d'auteurs ont tourné autour de cette
idée
il ya un grand tort de la renaissance en
italien castiglione qui appelle ça la
sprezzatura c'est ne pas être trop figé
c'est faire un peu bouger le costume un
jésuite espagnol appeler ça les ans les
traducteurs français ont eu de la peine
à traduire ça et amelot grand traducteur
du xviie siècle a dit il faut dire que
je ne sais quoi et bien chez toutes les
personnalités vraiment forte que j'ai pu
rencontrer
il y avait du jeu ne sais quoi et il y
avait beaucoup de je ne sais quoi
chez micheline calmy rey à leur chère
madame la présidente en suisse
c'est d'autant plus difficile d'être
comme cela non en suisse je pense que
vous le savez la modestie c'est une
valeur très prisé et quand je suis entré
en fonction comme ministre des affaires
étrangères est conseillère fédérale moi
j'ai pas voulu la modestie pour mon pays
j'ai voulu que mon pays brille sur la
scène internationale qu'il puisse
défendre correctement ses intérêts et
alors quand une tête dépasse un petit
peu en suisse on lui donne des coups de
marteau sur la tête pour la faire
rentrer dans le rang donc ça a
effectivement pas été facile de sortir
du train train quotidien
vous en avez reçu beaucoup de coups ils
n'ont pas mal pas mal pas mal mais vous
avez marché sur beaucoup de pieds je
sais pas j'ai essayé de viser des
objectifs qui correspondait aux intérêts
de mon pays et j'ai pris les mesures
nécessaires pour ce faire et c'est vrai
que ça n'a pas toujours été très simple
ça c'est vrai mais je pense que c'est
important d'être capable de parce que ça
vaut pas la peine d'être élu et
d'occuper des fonctions exécutives au
niveau d'un état
si c'est pour faire ce qu'on fait tous
les prédécesseurs il ya il faut
s'adapter aux mouvements du temps il
faut s'adapter à ce qui se passe dans le
monde
quand on est ministre des affaires
étrangères pour pouvoir défendre des
intérêts de son pays
sortir du cadre
c'est le cas de vous c'est le cas
souvent nos interlocuteurs les hommes
d'état où les chefs d'état ont ce qu'on
appelle des éléments de langage qui ont
été préparés paru même où leur équipe et
leur équipe
et parfois ils en sortent vous êtes face
à kadhafi par exemple la suisse a des
otages là bas vous êtes sous la tente il
ya plusieurs représentants de l'europe
il vous provoque ben oui il me provoque
parce que c'était la fin d'un long
processus où on à la suisse a joué un
peu les rapports de force avec l'union
européenne pour essayer de faire sortir
les otages et alors là on se trouvait
dans une réunion du pardon un endroit
complètement ce réaliste une tente en
pleine ville de tripoli et il y avait là
une soixantaine de personnes des chefs
d'état comme berlusconi
le président berlusconi d'autres et moi
j'ai été me suis fait tout petit j'étais
la seule femme de toute la réunion
et puis après plusieurs blagues un peu
salace sexistes entre ces messieurs ne
vous a pas qu ils m'attaquent
il se tourne vers moi et il me dit vous
venez d'où j'ai dit je viens de genève
oui mais alors ça ça devrait pas exister
la suisse romande devrait appartenir la
france la suisse alémanique devrait
appartenir à l'allemagne la suisse
italienne devrait appartenir à l'italie
et alors là à notre grande surprise se
lève monsieur berlusconi
le premier italien et il dit écoutez
leader ça je vous laisse pas dire je
vous laisse pas dire une chose comme ça
et ça c'était pas du tout dans ces
disciplines de langage il a dit ça non
moi pendant la guerre
ma famille et moi même nous avons été
accueillis en suisse nous sommes restés
trois ans en suisse la suisse est un
pays de paix et d'accueil
alors s'il vous plaît tu n'en parlez pas
comme ça et ça a été terminé et vous
même vous ne vous faites pas si petit
que ça c'est assez rare vous soyez fait
petit en réalité ça m'arrive là par
exemple sous la tente je me suis fait
petit il vous invite à manger le méchoui
qu'est ce que vous lui répondit elle
choisit je peux pas je dois ramener
montage en suisse alors un sandwich
volontiers mme el mechri j'peux pas et
vous l'avait ramené l'otage on l'a amené
après encore quelques péripéties mais on
a fini par le ramener et ça c'était un
moment très émouvant parce que dans
toute cette affaire c'était pas une
affaire qui étaient très importantes
pour les intérêts de politique étrangère
mais c'était important parce qu'il y
avait la vie de deux otages en jeu et
pour toutes les personnes qui se sont
occupées de cette affaire à chaque fois
que nous avions que nous avons dû
prendre une décision
c'était véritablement une pesée eu égard
à la vie des otages qui est un rouge
j'existais très difficile alors le
moment où on a ramené le dernier otage
on a tous pleuré
vous êtes face à vladimir poutine là
aussi chacun commence à sortir de son
cadre en réalité lui se met à dessiner
la cité j'ai été le voir en 2007 parce
que comme chaque année le président
suisse va voir le président russe en a
des relations qui seront bonnes jeu que
je qualifierais de deux bonnes général
et puis je vais le voir et puis c'était
l'époque où la suisse se faisait la
défenseur de l'indépendance du kosovo et
alors là aussi m'attaque en disant c'est
une bêtise que ça allait servir de
précédent qu'il fallait pas défendre
l'indépendance du kosovo
je vous fais juste remarquer qu'avec la
crimée il a fait exactement la même
chose mais là il avait changé d'avis
m'enfin bref passons donc
j'argumente il argumente on est resté
trois heures ensemble
il a fini par s'énerver parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est très émotionnel
alors il a sorti un grand cahier comme
ça et puis s'est mis à dessiner la
situation qui prévalait vers la géorgie
vers le kosovo toute cette région des
balkans
et puis il s'est mis à dessiner à
expliquer la situation géostratégique de
l'endroit et il s'est mis la façon dont
il a présenté les choses on pouvait
presque prévoir la guerre de géorgie qui
est qui est survenue une année plus tard
vous dit poutine émotionnel il joue de
ses émotions évidemment il est fin
parfois ça c'est le métier aussi
on se souvient dans dans clinton par
exemple qui était à nations unies ici il
entraîne dans des salles et il salué
comme ça là et là et c est tout le monde
est un peu surpris en suisse parce
qu'avais personnes et c'est un truc des
américains évidemment complètement
superficielle est faux pour avoir l'air
d'avoir 7 pour avoir l'air sympa et pour
faire de beaux sourires cathédrale et
vous le faites naturellement mais je
salue les gens quand je les vois les
vrais juin quand il y en a pas ça vous
est arrivé vous deux surjouée la colère
justement de sortir toujours ses
éléments de langage pour aller pousser
un peu plus loin
ça m'est arrivé d'être très en colère
notamment la rigueur notamment avec
monsieur juncker
parce que monsieur car c'est pas gentil
bisounours 1 seconde et demie de la
suisse
en tout cas je crois pas qu'ils nous
aiment énormément et moi j'ai eu des
problèmes avec lui on avait terminé les
négociations sur la fiscalité de
l'épargné
dernier volet enfin tout était réglé et
monsieur juncker qui était alors premier
ministre au ministre des finances du
luxembourg traitant dès que la suisse
avait obtenu plus que les états membres
dont faisait partie le luxembourg alors
il n'était pas d'accord
il voulait rouvrir les négociations et
on s'est retrouvé en marge d'une
manifestation à zurich
et là vraiment on s'est engueulé mais
vraiment engueuler en plus dans un
endroit où on n'était pas censés avoir
du public mais où il y avait des gens
qui ont fini par se rassembler autour de
nous il nous regarde pas assurément
anglais et parfois il faut savoir
montrer les dents quand vraiment il ya
des gens qui exagèrent moi je suis je
suis toujours présent j'ai toujours été
très engagé dans la défense de mon pays
j'ai toujours été très fier d'être sud
mais alors quand on me match sur les
pieds et que je représente la suisse là
je viens vraiment méchante du doubs est
ce que ça vient cette forme de culot
d'audace beaucoup d'entre nous ont peur
et la peur est souvent bonne conseillère
pour pas tomber dans le grain de folie
la provocation et cetera ils ont peur en
permanence un peur de fâcher leurs chefs
leurs amis leurs cousins etc
vous n'avez souvent vous avez donné
l'impression de ne pas avoir peur ça
vient d'où
oh écoutez je ne peux pas dire ça parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a toujours c'est
pas toujours très très agréable un de
devoir être un peu agressive avec
quelqu'un c'est pas c'est pas
franchement la situation que je préfère
mais quand il faut le faire il ya
parfois c'est nécessaire de le faire
parce que si vous le faites pas vous
vous faites pas respecté donc à un
moment donné il faut voilà il faut et
puis il faut voir l'objectif aussi il
faut toujours voir l'objectif si c'est
nécessaire pour atteindre un objectif
pour convaincre l'autre pour lui dire
écoutez ça va pas vous pouvez pas nous
traiter de cette façon il ya une certain
respect à avoir envers un pays même si
on n'est pas une grande puissance
bref il faut y aller quoi je vais dire
mais si on a un peu parfois mal au
ventre ça vous est arrivé devant lui
bien sûr vous donnez l'impression d'être
en téflon tout à l'heure avant d'entrer
sur scène moi je buvais des verdots
j'avais un peu le trac comme une
personne normale ou pas du tout vous
étiez là commun et je vous ai toujours
observé comme ça mais ça veut pas dire
parce que je montre pas que je n'ai pas
à huy vous parlez de vos origines
valaisanne ce côté très dur au mal ça
vous a servi
ben c'est peut-être un héritage oui
parce que nos ancêtres mais c'est pas
propre valère je pense à toute la suisse
nos ancêtres ont eu des conditions
difficiles c'était pas facile pour eux
certains ont dû émigrer gagner de
l'argent c'était pas évident et
aujourd'hui nous sommes un pays riche on
a peut-être oublié un peu ses origines
paysannes durs à la tâche et économe
mais il en reste peut-être quand même
quelque chose parfois
quels conseils vous avez des étudiants
aujourd'hui je vous entendais parler
tout à l'heure avec les étudiants vous
leur disiez il suffit plus parler
l'anglais l'allemand fois commencé avec
le russe ou chinois mais ce je ne sais
quoi ce qui fait que on aux consorts
simplement effectivement d'être un
dossier parmi 200 ou 500 ou 1000 c'est
quoi pour les étudiants c'est difficile
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est peut être
plus difficile que ça l'a été pour ma
génération
parce que vous êtes en concurrence et
surtout dans le domaine où j'enseigne
celui des relations internationales
quand un poste se libère dans une
organisation internationale ou dans une
ong
il ya 600 candidats donc c'est vraiment
très très dur il faut essayer de trouver
la toux qui vous fait aller au delà
c'est un peu comme la suisse sur la
scène internationale on vit dans un
monde interdépendant et si on veut
pouvoir défendre nos intérêts il faut
faire il faut travailler avec ses amis
et pour vous c'est la même chose il faut
travailler avec vos atouts ça veut dire
que il faut apprendre une langue
difficile parce que l'anglais le
français l'allemand tout le monde me
parle donc ça c'est naturel par contre
si vous voulez être actif que ce soit en
suisse ou ailleurs il vous faut
maîtriser un certain nombre de langues
un peu plus un peu plus difficile et
puis il faut essayer d'aller au bout de
vos spécialisation montrer que vous êtes
bon dans votre domaine et je sais que ça
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de concurrence
et c'est beaucoup plus difficile
aujourd'hui pour vous et surtout un
exercice comme celui-là apprendre à
parler à prendre à convaincre apprendre
à avoir des dialogues avec des gens et
essayer de parce que la peur ça vous
paralyse quoi je veux dire quelque part
donc c'est que l'expérience est là la
pratique qui peut vous faire sortir de
vous même aller au delà de vos peurs et
pouvoir convaincre
et puis avoir un bon job et puis ensuite
avoir du plaisir dans ce que vous faites
et vous sentir en adéquation avec vous
même il faut y aller vous dit même quand
on a peur il faut y aller
ben il faut avoir un certain wii un
certain courage il faut il faut parce
que sinon si vous restez assis dans
votre canapé à l'ère des romans
policiers
ça va pas le faire ils arrivent au
moment où on est dépassé
je veux dire il ya toujours plus
audacieux que ce soit un moment on
parlait d'une petite fille qui est plus
à gauche que vous possible
oui oui c'est très facile et alors qu'on
tient bon quand même
on est on apprend on apprend à lui monté
on apprend dans le commerce avec les
autres dans mon enseignement à
l'université j'organise des simulations
négociations on apprend à écouter celui
qui est en face à se mettre à sa place à
argumenter et à défendre ses positions
et ça je trouve ça très très important
pour votre vie future
merci micheline calmy rey merci à vous
[Applaudissements]